It's true that I work a lot
the idea of ​​work is associated in the tradition especially Christian to a
servitude navarra a kind of conviction
divine
well yes I do not feel it like that because I or let's say
living among books reading books and writing books is a supreme pleasure
for me
Of course, erika cio still demands discipline
obstacles that have to be overcome
making the balance
it is an extraordinary pleasure to say to write a novel that would not force
mossad
a ap develop certain activities travel interviews
a type of documentation that you have is that of a mathematical scientist
very free documentation
and seeing little by little how a story is being constructed
that simulates life that simulates free will
it's something exciting, I'm still excited as when I wrote my
first stories twice
and he added that free time
before when I had food work because I dedicated something that
it was for me a real pleasure not
and now I'm lucky to be able to devote almost all my time to that
so my productivity actually comes from that what
for me to write
more than a job it is an immense pleasure not